Currently the monolith service
does not have any end points.
One way to troubleshoot an issue
like this is to use a kubecti
get pods command with
a label [INAUDIBLE].
We can see we have a couple of pods
running with a monolith label.
But what about app=monolith,
and secure=enabled.
Notice that this label query
does not print any results.
But what about our secure monolith pods?
Let's see what labels they have.
It seems like we need to add
the secure=enabled label to them.
We can use the kubecti label
command to add the missing secure=
enable label to secure monolith pod.
Let's describe the secure-monolith
pod to see if it worked..
And now that it's correctly labeled,
let's see the list of imports
on the monolith- service.
And we have one,
let's hit one of the nodes again.
Bam!
Houston we have contact.